NICK BONINO GETTING A CHANCE TO
SKATE ON THE TOP LINE WITH
COUTURE AT CENMILTON, BEFORE TH,
>> Bret: MERCER GETS A LITTLE
BIT OFS OFF
THE IRONT LOOKS LIKE HE IS
GOING TO THAT.
HATA
YOYON STRIDE
ONE ON TWO, TRIED TO DINAY IN
THE OFFENSIN
NOW IT'S DAHLEN FILLING THE GAP.
HE'S WITH BONINO
POSTINTER THE GOAL.
>> Bret: THEY ARE GETTING GOOD
LINEBOARDS
HATAKKA HEAD BANDS IT FOR GET OD
HERE
AS WE MENTIONED THEY DID NOT
SCORE IN
THEYCK IS GOING TO COME RIGHT
THROUGH THAT SEAM.
THAT'S HIS MAN R RLTY  STICK BR.
BONINO STEPS IN FRONT OFCAN THEE
BARBABANOV IN AND AROUND WANTED
HERTL HERE IN THE THIRD PERIOD
THIS WAS A BEAUTY OFE THE DEVIL0
AHEAD OF THE SHUTDOWN. GRAVES.
HIS SHOT BLOCKED
IT WAS
JONAH GADJOVICH.
HE'S GETTING OF POSITION
THEY SCORE THE PL-- BURNS WILL
START FOR THE SHARKS ALONG WITTW
GRAVES WAS DOING THE SAME TH THE
THIS WASNOV AGAINST DAMON
SEVERSON
HE WILL JUSTSTSIDE
TATAR NOT NEARLY HE'S ASEY WENTD
THAT PASS TO GETS HIS WAY TO CE.
DROPS IT FOR HERTL IT.
MAYBN END.
>> Randy: HERE'S LOGAN
>> Bret: LOGAN COMING IN, LEFT
TO RIGHT, JUSTE GOAL LINE.
>> Randy: NO KIND OF A NIGHT
FOR THE SHARKS
>> Randy: NOW THE KID,
>> Bret: I LIKE THIS PLA SHOT.
>> Randy: TOMAD IT'S STOPPED BY.
>>A CHANCE FOR REDEMPTION.
GAME ON